- Oh, yeah.
You see, Chippendale dancers,
or me when I used to do dancing,
they'll pull it a couple
times and stretch it,
and you pull it and
stretch it then let go.
All Chippendale dancers do that.
They don't just go to stage
and pull their pants down,
it'll be a noodle.
It'll be like,
what the fuck is this?
Now, you're dancing?
You gotta be kidding me, you know?
- [Interviewer] Okay, Ron.
Ron, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I'm originally from New York,
Bayside, Queens, New York,
where I got my degree.
I got my Bachelor's in education.
Bachelor's in theater.
I taught theater at the
Venture Theater School
in New Brunswick, New Jersey,
and then I went and got
my Master's in special ed
where I was teaching mentally handicapped.
I did it so many years ago,
they didn't call it autism,
they called it childhood schizophrenia.
Shows you how back and ancient.
I started teaching in
1977, no, 70, '76, '77.
- [Interviewer] You grew
you with both your parents?
- Yes, I was born and
raised by mom and dad.
She developed Parkinson's disease
so she was a bit hard to, you know,
to work with or deal with.
It was tough.
I mean, we all loved her and
we'd do our thing, you know.
Parkinson's doesn't
really shorten your life,
it just makes it not a
great life, you know?
We still got along as a family,
my dad held it together.
He's around today, he drives a car,
he's 103 years old.
My dad lives in Nashville, Tennessee.
My brother heads up a huge corporation.
He's works for them
and he went to Harvard.
I have a cousin, my female cousin
who I helped to get her first job
as a waitress up in
the Catskill Mountains.
A lot of Jews went up there
for fresh air, you know?
And so she works for the
government, very high ranking.
We're all very proud,
she went to Stanford.
My mom was spy during World
War II because she was
behind enemy lines a couple of times.
So my dad built towers in the Philippines
to try to keep it
pro-America, not so Japanese.
It's a great family, very
good, hardworking, intelligent,
proud to call myself a Jeremy.
That's only my name.
- [Interviewer] How did you
end up getting into porn?
- The job market was so hard, difficult
to get work because
everybody wants to do it
in New York, Los Angeles,
Florida, Chicago.
People, you know, their driving a taxi
and the first thing to say
is, well, I'm driving a cab,
however, I'm actually an actor.
I'm actually a writer.
I'm actually a songwriter.
You know, I wrote that.
Yeah, everyone wants to be a performer
so that it was a horribly
difficult job market.
So I kind of settled.
I met a guy named Joe Sarno
who was directing regular movies.
We hung out, we chatted
and he goes, listen,
I got some weird news for ya.
I saw the pictures I did in
Play Girl magazine, which I did.
John Ritter was on the cover,
which I'll tell you later
on how coincidental that is,
but he wasn't nude or
anything, but he was skimpy,
you know, bathing suit when
Three's Company was hot.
So John Ritter, he was on the cover,
I was inside the magazine
and years later me and John both suffered,
you know, heart problems,
in the aortic, heart problems,
vascular heart problems.
And we both had an aortic
dissection at the same time.
Him in Kaiser, me at Cedar Sinai.
He passed away, he didn't make it.
I did and I'm here to talk about it.
So I'm one of the very
few people who actually
have survived aortic dissection.
And in fact, CNN called me a bad ass,
for driving myself to the hospital.
I was driving myself to the hospital.
So I was doing theater, went to Joe.
Joe said, I'll put you
in a movie, but my films
are no longer R-rated, I'm shooting porn.
And he was actually almost
a legendary director.
He went to Sweden he used to shoot.
He was very well known,
very well respected.
I said to Joe, maybe I'll do it then.
He goes, well, if you can do it.
I asked my friends and
family what they thought.
And at that time I was teaching
mentally challenged kids.
I was doing theater in New York.
And then I got this
option to make some money
because you make dick when
you're trying to be an actor.
And so I gave it a shot,
asked my family what they think.
And I said, you know, it
just kinda sleazy doing porn
but then again, I'm sleazy,
maybe it's a perfect match.
So I went and did it.
I was able to do it.
People saw that I had a
larger than average schmekel
so I took out the schmekel
right out of the pants.
Balls deep, and then I
have your first lesson.
- [Interviewer] What year was that?
- That was 1978.
1977 we shot it, 1978 they
were adding more scenes.
And then all of a sudden
me and John Ritter
had our problem.
Isn't that crazy?
And then years later, John
had a bigger problem and died.
Amy Yazbek, his wife, an actress sued,
because there were
mistakes made supposedly.
He was being held under observation.
My doctors at UCLA and at Cedar Sinai
said there's no observation for you, Ron.
We want to bring you right
into operation right now.
You're lucky you're alive.
How long's the operation?
10 hours.
Oh, and how long am I
going to be recuperating?
A month.
I had plans tomorrow.
Not anymore.
I had a wedding.
There you have it.
Cute little Indian guy kept me alive.
Everyone said he saved my life.
He wouldn't let me go.
Which I love the guy for it.
I needed a second operation.
I was bleeding internally.
Some doctors will go iffy on that because
are you gonna survive or not?
He was not gonna let me go.
You know, this guy is gold.
Others have seen him
since, I referred them.
Amir Shah.
My cardiologist,
Ernst Schwartz.
Those were the two guys.
- [Interviewer] 1978,
certainly the porn industry
has changed a lot in all
these years since right?
- The business has changed
like you would believe.
And I thought it was changing a lot
when it went from film to
video to VHS to Betamax,
the internet, the interactivity,
to virtual reality,
To ridiculous dialogue.
Hi, where are you from?
Okay who ordered the large sausage?
How come you don't have
the money to pay for it,
to other scenes where
amateur, it was like what you gonna do
when they come for you.
You know, you look out
the window of your home.
They go, hey look,
looks like the same cops
we just saw on television.
Some bitch, that is the same cops.
So it became more like goofy,
like just those crazy dialogue scenes.
Then it got classy.
Films like a "Cafe Flesh", "Roommates",
Joe Vincent, Anthony Spinelli,
some famous directors like Wes Craven.
We did "Nightmare on Elm Street."
Adelson, John Adelson, I think did some,
either soft core or hard core.
It was becoming almost,
almost publicly acceptable
to do this because it just was acceptable.
They even made a satire.
The judge wouldn't allow,
they prosecuted some
of these porn films.
And the judge in New
York tried to let some
of it go, try to remind people
this is freedom of speech.
These are performers.
And it was a very touch-and-go situation.
They eventually beat it,
I think Harry Reems, Linda Lovelace,
and there you have it.
Porn was kind of boring.
And then it went to, like I said,
more highly advanced science.
They started going to interactivity.
And now, like I said,
virtual reality and now
and in the internet,
now a large part of the
business is cam girls.
They'll walk around with a computer.
Hi, Bob, look, isn't this girl pretty?
This is me.
We hope you win the award tonight.
That's a large part of the business.
Now it's the cam girls are
a large part of the biz
and before they were not and
the public seems to like it,
got male talent does not like it.
Guys in porn because not a
lot of work for them anymore.
Now it's just you and the consumer.
Hi Bob, should I pull down my panties?
Yeah, please.
How's that for a nasty voice?
Yes, pull them all the way down.
Good.
Now come over here and
sit right on my face.
- [Interviewer] The
industry's been good to you.
You obviously became the most famous
porn actors ever, right?
- Nobody argues that, it's worldwide.
When I went to Europe and I
was shooting films in Italy,
Remini Richioni, Fiorenza, Florence
and Roma with Rocco Cicciolina
and all these people.
You know I worked internationally
and I did great with it.
Mario Solarity, Mario Altieri, Mario Pola
Ricardo Skeeky.
Cicciolina became the only, or the first,
let's see what happens now, diplomat
to actually attain office as a porn star.
Cicciolina was a Hungarian.
Alona Staller is her real name.
And she talked like a
dis, hello Ron Jeremy.
And so we did a couple of scenes together
and I admired the fact that in Italy,
the Parliament voted in a porn star
and she has that title for life.
Not the one pawn star, being a diplomat.
I thought that was too cool.
And then woke up the next morning, joking.
Giuseppe, see what's on the radio.
Some porn star just got
into the Parliament.
I voted for her.
So did everybody else?
What the? Well I'll be.
She became the only...
And then she got not allowed
to come into America.
Seems to me we discussed
this before, it's interesting
because she was trying to make a deal
with terrorists and
America doesn't do that.
She gave a big speech
where she said that if
Saddam Hussein, when he had
those captive Americans,
who let them go, if she'll have...
Saddam was saying we'll
let the girls go and guys
she'll have sex with him.
American government took
it a little too serious
and banned her from ever
coming into America.
So she would came in through
Canada because she had a child,
she had a son, she had a custody battle.
Jeff Koontz, very famous
artist out of New York.
So he won his,
he won the right to have custody.
She won the right to have custody.
Somebody's got to give up something.
- [Interviewer] What personality traits
do you think you have or porn actor needs
to survive naked and thrive.
- Finding the humor in
anything and everything.
Nothing can't be too funny
or unfunny, you know?
It's allowing yourself to
make a fool of yourself
and then shine right afterwards.
- [Interviewer] Were you
married? Do you have kids.
- No.
- Never?
I mean, I wouldn't mind.
I love kids and I used
to be a school teacher
and I would be a great dad,
but not a great husband.
I'd be into probably
that swinging lifestyle.
- [Interviewer] Yeah but
there are some people
who are into that.
- Lot of them are,
especially in our business.
Are you?
- [Interviewer] No, I'm
straight as an arrow,
but I'm totally accept and
respect people's choices
to do all the fun stuff.
That's just not my thing.
But porn actors I've
talked to have all said
most of them said, you kind
of need to stick with somebody
in the industry in order to
have a successful relationship.
- Was it a guy or girl?
- [Interviewer] Both.
- I wouldn't say it's
totally true, but they heard
that expression opposites can attract.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- In a way, it certainly
does give you an added boost,
I think, you know.
- [Interviewer] There's always
exceptions to every rule.
- Yeah but (indistinct).
You have more of an understanding.
You don't sweat the small stuff.
You know, you accept the
fact that maybe we're here
to be emotionally
monogamous, travel together,
hold hands, look at scenery,
go to the Grand Canyon
and physically non-monogamous, you know
because it's easier to do that.
It's very hard.
- [Interviewer] It's hard for a lot
of people to separate it.
- I had my name on a swing club.
It was called Ron Jeremy's
Club, CESO in Portland, Oregon.
It did good.
Did real good.
And I saw how people were
and it was really a good lesson
that, you know if you can get past
the jealousy you can have a good time.
It doesn't mean you have
to play hide the bacon
and shoot the sherbet, drain the main vein
and squeeze the weasel.
You don't have to do that.
You can just simply be with your own wife,
your own husband and watch other people.
And that's a turn-on when
you look experimental.
There you go.
If you get into that lifestyle,
it can be a lot of fun
and share it with the
person that you care about
and you don't let it get too far.
You just having a little physical fun,
then get back together again
for another few months,
few years whatever.
You feel the itch to be
with some other flesh.
It doesn't detract from the romance.
People are always afraid
of that, it's not.
And if you are afraid of that
do something where it's too far to get to
like Maui, Hawaii or Key West, Florida.
If you do things down there,
you haven't got as much to worry about
'cause it's too big a deal to
go to those exotic locations.
So you and your wife, or
you and your girlfriend
or whatever, can just
enjoy a nice romance.
- [Interviewer] What is
it about the act of sex
that pushes people's buttons?
So many people get worked
up over it, whether it's--
- Meaning in a bad way.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, like shame
or there's violence
connected with it sometimes.
And there's all kinds of weird.
- It's a shame because you shouldn't
get worked up all over
it, it's a fun thing.
I mean, I liked that Hustler
had a very nice slogan.
It was called Relax, It's Just Sex.
I like that.
(indistinct)
Yeah, it's true.
It was making too big a deal about it.
Just have fun.
You want to do something, do it.
You don't, don't.
And what's funny too, is that they said,
you can get hurt, God knows why.
And Bill Margold had a great expression.
He said, "you're not gonna
get hurt watching porn.
Nobody ever died watching
porn unless they got too close
to the VCR and got electrocuted."
It's true.
What I debate the XXX Church,
Guy named Craig Groves.
We've been all over the world debating
and I've made it a point to say that,
which has done more to kill people?
Religion or adult movies.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- Everything we do here is good.
- [Interviewer] You must
get recognized when you're
out in public, right?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And do
you, have fans that come
up to you, what kind of
reactions do you get?
- Hey dude, what's so-and-so like?
Does Christy Canyon really
got natural boobies or
hey do you guys got to take those tests?
Do you gotta do that?
Did you have to do gay films
before you did straight films
and those are some of the ones.
Do your parents know what you're doing?
Your sister know what you're doing?
Your cousin, best friends, girlfriend?
They know what you're doing?
- [Interviewer] Do women fall in your lap
because you're Ron Jeremy?
- Say what?
- [Interviewer] Do
women fall into your lap
because you're Ron Jeremy?
- Well I certainly wish
they would more often
but yes, I get some of
that once in a while.
- [Interviewer] How many
women have you had sex with?
- Let's see, whenever guys asked me that,
I have a very funny answer.
I always say, including
your mom, I had one, two.
But around 3,600.
I do a joke about it, my comedy act.
Me and Gene Simmons
were asked that question
by Barbara Walters on
two separate occasions.
I said, look, this is Gene Simmons.
He gets girls that look
like his Playboy playmate,
Shannon Tweed, whom he married.
Me, when I'm not working, I get girls
that look like Gene Simmons.
That's not a rehearsed
joke, of course not.
That's a fair answer, really.
I'm about 30, 36, 3,600 women.
- [Interviewer] What's the
most misunderstood thing
about the porn industry?
- The industry, or me?
- Either one.
- Or both.
- For me, people think that
we're calling the school yards,
looking for girls.
Hey wanna get in the business, come on.
Not like that at all.
Now it's the cam girls
and girls who are working as escorts.
Some act topless clubs
and nude clubs, you know?
So it's like in the old volunteer,
they'll get the ads in the paper.
And then LA Direct Models are
Mark Spiegler, Jim South.
These guys get the phone
calls for the work.
And then the girl comes
in, does an interview
like anything else?
The people who really
hate the industry think
that it doesn't do that.
That the person's like soliciting you.
They're not!
There are a lot of girls
who want to do this.
And now the cam girls, where
it's just you and the consumer.
The guy on the, it's a
whole different ball game.
It really is just the girl and the fan.
So that's where a lot
of adult film actors,
are not working anymore.
A lot of my friends are
not doing porn anymore
because it isn't the work.
There was a woman I
think in North Carolina
who got fired because she was
discovered as a porn star.
Look, it's gonna happen.
If you've got to think of a career
of being a school teacher,
don't do adult films today.
You know?
So that's happened where has
there been discrimination?
Sure, sure.
You know, there are women
who have had a raw deal.
Men, not as often, but women, yes.
- [Interviewer] What are the downsides
of porn, a career in porn?
What kind of negatives have you seen?
- Well, what I just said
it was positive and good
and it feels good, it's fun to do.
In the same logic, works
against you as well.
You know, because if you're a porn star
and your wife really believes,
or girlfriend believes
that for love of money, that's it.
You're gonna play around
for love of money.
If it's a brothel and I'm
gonna mess around with a guy
or something, I'm helping
her on the bread winning
then I'm gonna earn us a living
and you can kick in and
work at the gas station
where you were before.
And this way we'll all have fun.
So sometimes you know
that, which makes porn fun
and you're tough enough to take it
'cause your wife or girlfriend loves you
and they're just gonna watch
some other couple, you know?
The good is, it works.
I've seen it work really well.
The bad is it might not work.
You know, hey dude, that's my girl.
You're at a swing club,
put a sun on your forehead.
- [Interviewer] What's the longest
romantic relationship
you've had in your life.
- Nine and three quarter inches.
I love that one.
The longest.
Margie, Alice, Tanya.
Margie four years.
Alice four years.
I was in high school at the time.
Alice, four years.
Tanya, I was already going to college
and then going into porn,
that was like two years.
It was four years, four years, two years.
And then,
Venice and I were more like
friends from the very beginning.
Venice and then Natalie,
friends for 15 years.
Best friends.
She has a bunch of adorable
children, and I'm uncle Ron.
Whenever I show up, the car pulls up
to where they're living, in the South,
and the girls will come
running out of the house.
Uncle Ron, Uncle Ron.
How do you beat that?
It's kind of things that I like,
people wouldn't expect that I like.
- [Interviewer] You must have some
incredibly interesting stories
from your illustrious career, right?
Share a story or two of something
fun in the porn industry.
- I'm in Majorca, Spain.
We had done some stuff in Spain.
And then now I'm shooting
"America On the Ocean."
I took Bonine pills, which
John Leslie told me to take.
And it was a really all-star cast.
Nacho Vidal from Spain;
Rocco from Italy, Cicciolina,
Monapotsi, a lot of the big
European stars were on the boat.
Everybody threw up.
I did not because John
Leslie saved me, you know
with these pills that really work.
But the girl would be bent
over the edge of the boat
and rather than blowing
me, she's blowing chunks.
And so then I told the director,
we really gonna do this?
And Mario Solari with a girl
named Solen, beautiful girl.
It was, look, these girls are gonna
have sex with you Ron.
We need to get the shots.
They're throwing up.
We can all deal with it.
Girls?
It's okay.
So I did a sex scene with two girls
and while they were shooting,
they shot the action.
They shot the hardcore,
you know, right there.
Uncircumcised dicks a lot of the time boys
and they'd pan up and down this far
and you'd see hardcore action.
And then when they got to shore,
the nice thing about
seasickness is it goes away
once you're on the shore.
So we get to the shore.
Everyone felt great.
I was the only one who did not get ill.
Anyway, the cameraman got sick,
makeup artists got sick.
The chef got sick and I never did.
So then now they shot me in
the girl with their faces
against the sky and going
to the same dialogue,
oh baby, oh yeah, oh, uh, uh.
And so, that was a cum shot.
Here's sperm in the throat
(vocalizing) thank you.
So when we got back to shore
we shot the footage we needed
and just doesn't show the action.
'Cause during that portion it was vomit.
So it worked out fine.
And so to this very
day, you see that scene
you can know that while
the scene was being shot,
everybody was vomiting.
And when I was doing
the make-believe like,
oh yeah, oh baby, oh
yeah, that was all fake.
Interesting huh?
The magic of movie making.
- [Interviewer] Yes, there's
always stories like that
in every industry, right?
Do you ever wish that you had
chosen a different career?
- I guess we all do that
sometimes 'cause I was going
for a mainstream career.
I didn't choose porn.
You know, I wanted to do that.
- [Interviewer] Came up in Boston, right?
- Good for you.
It was Joe Sarno and he, again,
a very well-known filmmaker
of like B quality, but it was good.
People liked his stuff.
And that's where it all began.
Him and a guy named Dylan Ross brought me
onto various sets to see how it goes.
Said, Ron, what do you say?
And there you have it.
I said I'll give it a try.
- [Interviewer] I think
your personality is if
you don't take things seriously.
You look at everything with a little--
- Grain of salt.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I think that helps.
- But you want to be good
and put on a good show.
I mean, you really want to, you have to.
- People think, oh, it's just porn.
Just porn my ass, it's selling.
Remember I was there during the heyday.
They called it the golden years.
There were thousands of
tapes, DVD's, VHS's, internet,
all coming along, being born.
You got to take it seriously.
If you want to become a porn star,
you can't just hope.
You gotta take it like
any other acting job.
Get up on time.
If it's a girl, have your hair in curlers.
Go to the set on time.
I mean a porn film back in
the seventies and eighties
it was just like a regular movie.
That was a low budget.
It was like a trauma film.
Or it was like a Trey Parker, Matt Stone,
like a South Park project.
They don't believe in
unions or now they do
but they were doing low budget B movies
with a real funny twist
that was hysterically funny.
I worked for them.
I was one of the leads in Orgasmo.
I also had a lead, or a major
part In Boondock Saints.
Huge film.
Willem Defoe plays an FBI agent
who's gay and solves crimes.
I've done about a hundred
and some odd regular movies.
- [Interviewer] You've done
quite a bit of mainstream work.
- What?
- [Interviewer] You've done
quite a bit of mainstream work.
- Oh yeah I did that.
I have the world's record.
Most music videos.
Nobody's even close.
Matt LeBlanc did 11.
I did 56 music videos.
- [Interviewer] What were
the best years of your life?
What was the best time of your life?
- I'd say when I was
making really great accomplishments.
I wrote a book that was a
New York Times bestseller.
I did a rap song and I
can't rap worth a shit.
But I did good at it and it
was called Clip of the Week
with DJ Polo, Ice Tea, Sir Mix A Lot,
Grandpa Munster, Linwood Grave,
had a lot of stars in it.
- [Interviewer] What was
your family's reaction
when you became a huge porn star?
- They were hoping that
I'd go on to better stuff.
I told them it's only a
means to an end, you know?
So I said, oh, that's a means to an end.
- [Interviewer] But you turned it into,
you probably made a lot of money.
You've probably made a lot of money here.
- I didn't make a ton
because they think that
we're millionaires.
We're not, we're a thousandaires.
You know, the girls will
make a couple of grand.
I'll make a couple of
grand once in a while.
Otherwise there'll be maybe a few hundred
if it's a gang scene, or
a bunch of guys, one girl.
A bunch of girls, one guy.
It depends on the scene.
But it's not what people think.
I looked at the internet
and saw the figures
they gave me and Jessica Jane.
The late great Christy
Canyon was in there.
I saw what they were writing,
they were way off base.
They're saying, well these
people they're millionaires.
No they're not, not even close.
So you don't really
always get the true answer
in some of the stuff.
We don't make what people think we do.
- [Interviewer] And where
does your career go from here?
How old are you now?
- Oh you bastard.
- [Interviewer] Sorry I
won't ask, I won't ask.
- Oh come on 66
- 66.
But you still look great.
- What?
- [Interviewer] You still look great
and you're still working
- Well, thank you for that.
And I am still doing
scenes, I didn't stop.
Some people thought I
stopped, no I still work.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Too much fun to quit.
- [Interviewer] How many
films have you done?
- I have the world's record in porn too,
but about 3,500.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
What are you most proud of in your life?
- That I did a rap song
called Sexy and I know It.
I was in it, you see me in three spots
and went on to become 150 million hits.
Or half a billion hits
on Sexy and I Know It.
I had about 1,000, no,
about a half a billion people
saw me sing good night,
actually wait a minute.
It was Auld Lang Syne.
It's funny.
This is definitely one you'll appreciate.
This was on CNN on the
Anderson Cooper show.
Remember him?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So he, him and Kathy Griffin invited me
on the show, said, it's
gotta be 14 seconds.
So I did a 14 seconds
salute Auld Lang Syne,
right on target.
My friend Adam Rifkin shot it.
And I was seen by half
a billion people on HBO.
Hopefully it's something
like this, two seconds.
(harmonica music)
- [Interviewer] You're very good.
- Thank you, you ought to see me on piano.
You ought to see me on violin.
A lot of the big name rock stars have said
that I'm as good as they are.
I played violin, harmonica and piano.
- [Interviewer] You have
other careers as a comedian
and musician as well.
- Yeah, if you look at the
Kid Rock song called Cowboy,
wanna be a cowboy baby.
I was on the piano on that song.
- [Interviewer] Really? That's great.
- Cowboy.
And I played with the
Celtic band in Ireland.
So yeah, I've had a lot of fun.
I've done a lot of fun
things, it's been great.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I think your attitude
has kind of facilitated
you just having fun
while you're doing your career
and all these side venture.
- Sure.
- [Interviewer] And your personality
is just very easygoing--
- Well thank you.
- [Interviewer] Light and charming.
I think that's paved the
way for all the success
and all the kind of--
- Yeah, thank you--
- [Interviewer] ease that
you have going through life
in what could be a
really troubling career.
- Of course.
- [Interviewer] Some people don't survive
and thrive like you have.
- Well, that's sad.
Look, actresses and actors have
problems all over Hollywood.
They used to say that Alan Alda is so nice
and so friendly and has so few scandals,
he couldn't find a dog
mean enough to bite him,
because he was known for
being the real sweet,
never cheated on his wife.
Alice Cooper never cheated on his wife.
I mean, it's certain things,
they say Howard Stern
never cheated on his wife.
Now, is that true or false?
Who knows?
But it's funny, because
point was very accurate.
It depends on how you
get into the business.
I used to tell that to
kids I was teaching about
when you want to continue with a job
or try a different one, I say that
if you come into a
business with a level head,
you're professional, you're on time.
I don't care if you're a dishwasher.
I don't care if you're
cleaning fire hydrants
or a porn star.
You know, if you keep your head level,
you take yourself
professionally, take it serious.
You can have fun, in fact, you should.
But if you can do that,
then you'll do well because you're just
allowing yourself not to
be taken too seriously
'cause of this particular career
but you'll have fun and
you'll make money and you know
it's a career like anybody else.
- [Interviewer] All right
Ron, well thank you so much
for talking to me.
- Nice questions.
Very well designed.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.